[Music]
on this Monday night Israel's growing
ground of salt in southern Gaza as
critical supplies run out Palestinians
say they have nowhere left to run we're
tired this is enough and why some
Israelis are calling for their prime
minister to quit they don't think of
Godin as human beings minimizing methane
emissions ottawa's new plan for the oil
and gas industry bad news for Canada's
public broadcaster hundreds laid off at
the
CBC and that runaway Rue is now back at
the zoo incredibly grateful that this
thing was able to be caught how police
finally apprehended this slippery
marsupio global national with Donna FZ
reporting tonight Jeff simple good
evening and thank you for joining us
Palestinians in southern Gaza are
running out of places to escape Israel's
growing ground offensive the Israeli
military has called for Mass evacuations
in Han Yunis where thousands have taken
Refuge some residents say areas they
were told were safe are now being
hit since Israel's war in Gaza began
around 16,000 Palestinians have been
killed that's according to the Hamas run
Health Ministry including 6600 children
the head of one of the few functioning
hospitals called called the situation
catastrophic citing a lack of clean
water food and medicine and the sudden
surge in population in southern Gaza
means even fewer supplies to go around
as Crystal ganing Reports the new phase
of the conflict comes as Washington
calls on Israel to show restraint and a
warning some of the images in this story
are
distressing you can barely see the small
body amongst the large men frantically
Tri trying to free it what is visible
two bare feet and Tiny legs in black
pants Global is blurring because of the
disturbing nature it's not known If the
child
survived this is Rafa in southern Gaza
where Palestinians have been told to go
told it would be
safer there is no safe area neither Rafa
nor Han yunas or Gaza they are all
liars a new phase of the war is underway
according to military officials one that
includes Southern Gaza as Israel pursues
Hamas we will operate in maximum Force
against Hamas terrorist and
infrastructures while minimizing harm to
the civilian that Hamas places around
them as Shields Gaza is small roughly 41
km long and about 12 kilm wide as Israel
conducts military operations by air and
on the ground there's little space for
the estimated 2.2 million people to
go look here there's no resistance here
not Hamas not anything we are just women
in the house the early morning strike on
Han Yunis reportedly killed two people
the force of the blast left a car
scarcely recognizable as it's been
compressed with other
wreckage
hunis is the second largest city in Gaza
and with bombardments injured patients
flooded Nasser Hospital once again
protecting Palestinian civilians in Gaza
is both a moral
responsibility and a strategic
imperative strategic Lloyd Austin says
because Israel which has America's
support could end up driving
Palestinians into the arms of Hamas
people are on the move again following
Israeli or ERS but with no idea of where
to find safety as Israeli forces conduct
operations across
Gaza Crystal Ganson Global News
London families of Israeli hostages held
by Hamas are demanding a meeting with
Israel's war cabinet those families
gathered in Tel Aviv calling on the
government to prioritize the release of
their loved ones Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu is also fighting a
legal battle his corruption trial
resumed today it was put on hold
following the October 7th attack by
Hamas Netanyahu is the first Israeli
Prime Minister to be a criminal
defendant he denies any wrongdoing and
claims to be the victim of a carefully
orchestrated political plot Daniel hjin
reports from Jerusalem on the calls for
Netanyahu to step
down they want him out of office and
behind
bars after 16 years they say Benjamin
Netanyahu known as BB is unfit to serve
this country for many reasons m guzov is
a Canadian Israeli she says Netanyahu
has been prime minister for most of her
life I'm so ashamed that they represent
me they don't think of Godin as human
beings I don't think and I am terrified
of what will happen in this war if
they're if they stay in
control we're outside the Israeli
Parliament where protests are held
several times a week they're shouting
things like BB has blood on his hands
that he's a liar and that he's a danger
to the
state it's a small but noisy crowd on
the other side of the barricade the
crowd is even
smaller with one man standing
defiant first of all I think Israel
should occupy Gaza I think the
Palestinians in Gaza should go I think
we should have a population and move the
population to other
countries once on the fringes calling
for the force displacement of
Palestinians is now the kind of rhetoric
normalized under
Netanyahu he actually believes that he
is the Messiah that he is the one that
saves Israel and there is something
about him no one can replace him we are
saturated by genocidal
incitement a deal with ultra nationalist
parties with openly anti-arab lawmakers
is what keeps Netanyahu in power
together they form the most right-wing
government the state of Israel has ever
known since October 7th one Minister
suggested to Nuke Gaza another Member of
Parliament called for a second nakba
implying the ethnic cleansing of
Palestinians earlier this year while on
trial for corruption charges Netanyahu
unveiled a plan to overhaul the judicial
system that triggered months and months
of mass protests the fear that power
would be concentrated in the hands of
just one man among those who took to the
streets was yel Alon but she's here
today for a different reason you lost
your father in the war of 73 and your
son in the war of 2023 what is your
message to the government
H they have to go home they fail a big
fail failure they're responsible for
what happened you holding them
responsible for the death of your
son yeah there is a kind of
understanding here in Israel that
whatever political implications and
backlash is in the in the cards will
only erupt when the war is over so that
is why he has an interest to prolong the
War the longer the war the longer BB
will likely remain in power Danielle
hamam Jin Global News
Jerusalem Global Affairs Canada confirms
another Canadian has been killed in the
Israel Hamas conflict the government
says the victim was in Lebanon but
offered no further Details Ottawa says
seven Canadians and a person with close
connections to Canada have been killed
in the fighting since Hamas attacked
another Canadian is still missing and is
believed to be held hostage in Gaza
thousands of demonstrators gathered on
Parliament Hill for a rally in support
of Israel among the speakers was the
mother of Alex L A Montreal man killed
when Hamas attacked the Nova music
festival today we want to channel this
immense pain into a call for
Action supporters call it a show of
strength against Rising anti-Semitism
many in the crowd also demanding the
release of the remaining Hamas
hostages
and also in Ottawa Canada's largest
Muslim youth group is hosting a
multifaith gathering tonight called
voices for peace dozens of leaders from
Jewish Muslim and Palestinian groups are
attending in New Brunswick monton city
council is reversing a controversial
decision to not allow a manora and
nativity scene outside City Hall the
manura has been lit up there for 20
years the decision to end that tradition
up upset members of the Jewish Community
today mt's mayor apologized saying the
city wanted to be more inclusive but
that it obviously fell short in that
transition a manur lighting ceremony
will take place on Thursday evening when
Hanukkah
Begins the federal government has
unveiled a new plan to cut methane
emissions from the oil and gas sector by
at least 75% an effort to support
cleaner energy and climate action
Canada's environment Minister made that
pledge at the UN climate Summit in Dubai
Abigail Bean reports on the regulations
and
reaction we're now aiming for at least
75%
reduction 75% fewer methane emissions by
2030 Canada unveiled new draft
regulations about how to get there and
promised $30 million for a new methane
Center of Excellence focused on tracking
and Reporting the accuracy and
understanding of how much and where
methane is emitted and that is reported
properly is critical to achieving
methane targets methane emissions
largely come from either leaks or
venting and flaring gas released into
the atmosphere when oil is pulled from
the earth the draft regulations Target
both every molecule of methane uh packs
a a much greater Greenhouse punch than
carbon dioxide climate experts and
Advocates welcome the announcement but
they're also watching for how it will be
implemented and believe better tracking
and Reporting through the new center are
key those calculations are notoriously
inaccurate um they tend to be very slow
to update and as we're in this phase of
rapidly changing methane emissions
hopefully they're just inadequate the
governments of Saskatchewan and Alberta
are already pushing back with Alberta's
Premier calling the new regulations
costly dangerous and
unconstitutional while the Canadian
Association of petroleum producers
declined an interview saying in a
statement an overly complex and
prescriptive regulatory frame framework
can add delays and higher costs making
it more difficult to rapidly Implement
Technologies and processes that drive
emissions lower if we are going to
achieve our 1.5 degrees Targets this is
the way to do it quickly and efficiently
it's not that costly and it has a huge
impact Canada's announcement brings our
country in line with the US and at the
climate Summit in Dubai a coalition of
50 oil and gas companies globally
pledged to reduce methane emissions even
further 80 to 90% by 2030 Abigail Bean
Global News
Ottawa a well-known Pro democracy
activist from Hong Kong says she's fled
to Canada and is unlikely to return
Agnes Chow says her personal safety and
mental health factored into her choice
which she announced in a social media
post she added that she won't return to
the city to meet her bail conditions
child was arrested in 2020 under
beijing's National Security Law which
was enacted after anti government
protests in 2019 Hong Kong's National
Security Department strongly condemned
Chow's
decision major cuts are coming to
Canada's public broadcaster some
effective immediately the CBC and Radio
Canada its French language arm plan to
slash about 10% of the workforce it
amounts to about 600 positions across
the organization with a mix of Union and
non-union jobs 200 additional vacancies
will not be filled the CBC says it's
dealing with a $125 million budget
shortfall those changes will take effect
over the next 12
months thousands of people across Quebec
are without power after the first major
snowstorm of the
Season close to 30 cm of snow fell in
Montreal today causing chaos on the
roads multiple flights were either
delayed or cancelled and several schools
across the province were forced to take
a snow day
and many kids across Nova Scotia also
took advantage of a day off Environment
Canada issued a snowfall warning for
that province with up to 25 cmers
expected in some areas Nova Scotia Power
says its crews are responding to outages
affecting around 20,000 customers caused
by the heavy snow and high winds from
ice and snow to molten lava coming up
the deadly volcanic eruption in
Indonesia
[Music]
that is Indonesia's Mount morup erupting
in the distance the volcano located on
the island of Sumatra is one of the
archipelago's most active morup is
spewing thick ash clouds 3 kilometers
into the air blanketing surrounding
Villages it's believed 75 people were on
the mountain when it started erupting
yesterday the bodies of 11 clim have
been recovered and 49 people have been
rescued so far more than 40 eruptions in
the last 24 hours have slowed search
efforts far an Asser on the work to find
the
missing Zira fabrina cries to her mother
for help the 19-year-old was on a hiking
trip with friends when Mount Mory
suddenly erupted on
Sunday dozens of Rescuers have been
taking turns carrying survivors down the
mountain through thick
brush they're also transporting the
bodies of the 11 climbers who didn't
make it crew say it took 6 hours to
recover the body of one of the victims
near the crater most are still
there 12 climbers are still missing says
the head of the local search and rescue
agency including the brother of this
man he says his brother was separated
from friends and sent him a video saying
he couldn't walk anymore officials say
not everyone who climbed registered so
many more to be missing Indonesia has
the largest number of active volcanoes
in the world Professor Glenn Williams
Jones has spent much of his career
climbing in studying them when we're
looking at a volcanic eruption you're
looking at temperatures on many hundreds
of degrees celsus exploding out really
like a bomb going off um and so it it
it's not surprising that that there were
fatalities Mora's deadliest eruption in
1979 killed 60 people since 200 four the
volcano has been erupting every 2 to
four
years those brave enough to climb this
weekend didn't think they would witness
the latest
one far Asser global
news so long Sinclair still ahead a look
back at the legacy of Canada's brightest
Soccer
[Music]
Star ch Sinclair is on the pitch today
preparing for an important match in
Vancouver tomorrow night this is her
final practice before her final game
with the Women's National Team NE ugara
reports on the BC athlete who became
Canada's biggest soccer star and one of
the greatest of all time she has more
goals than any other player male or
female in the world uh she's represented
Canada with so much respect and pride
and Leadership 190 goals more more than
330 International game appearances and
23 years later Canadian soccer Legend
Christine Sinclair is hanging up her
cleats on Sunday she walked into the
Vancouver Stadium which will be renamed
Christine Sinclair place for one night
in honor of her final game for her
country this is her last practice some
of my best memories of playing Youth
Soccer was on that field and now to know
that I'm finishing my International
career on that same field it's kind of
surreal
um yeah it's kind of come full circle
she deserves just to go out in full
glory and we are all so excited for this
Sinclair encouraged young women to get
involved in the sport and has fought for
equality including pushing for pay
equity on Parliament Hill equal the men
every chance that a guy gets I want a
girl to get we're moving in the right
direction but like at a very slow pace
Sinclair was 16 when she made her senior
debut for Canada in March March of 2000
at the time Canada's youngest ever
player as she gets set to retire at 40
the provincial government has proclaimed
December 12th as Christine Sinclair day
in British Columbia after a game against
Australia on Tuesday her career will
come to a close but teammates say her
Legacy will continue for Generations
neua Global News
Vancouver hi I'm Mike trle after a
weekend in the oswa outback a on the
is back in captivity I'll explain more
coming up on global
national welcome back a kangaroo that
kickstarted a wild goose chase in
Ontario has been captured it got the
jump on its handlers last Thursday
during a pit stop on Route to a Quebec
Zoo for over three days the marsupial
mystery dominated social media with
every reported sighting Mike tret
reports on the Tal's hoppy
ending UA's Most Wanted is back in the
zoo this is the only picture of the
high-risk takedown two police officers
and one kangaroo who didn't go quietly
whenever off will punch with Bas by with
the ru hunt began last Thursday when its
handlers who were transporting it to a
facility in Quebec stopped at the Ashawa
Zoo for a break they were trying to
unload her into our warm facility and um
unpredictably it jumped over them and
got away it ran across the road into
Farm fields and at night this thing is
very very difficult to find it didn't
take long for people to report sightings
Paul reinger was driving his son to
school and he goes yeah it is hopping I
go that's a kangaroo or a WABE or
something similar right but I go what
why is it what's going on others saw the
60 lb female speeding alongside the road
he's fast red kangaroos can reportedly
reach a top speed of 70 km per hour far
faster than Cameron Raa get him get him
who tried to catch her with a giant net
we got to be about within 5 ft of it
before it was able and as soon as it got
past us that was that was it Toronto has
seen its share of animals on the run
over the years none more notorious than
Bonnie and Clyde the Cappy bearers that
eluded capture for over a month back in
2016 yeah and a few years before that a
monkey wearing a shearling coat was
found roaming in Ikea with temperatures
dipping below freezing in the Ashawa
Outback Zoo officials say they're
thankful the Wayward marsupial was only
gone for a long weekend I'm just I'm
both flabbergasted and Incredibly
grateful that this thing was able to be
caught you know what they say Durham
Police always get their marup Mike drite
Global News Joshua
Ontario and that is global national for
this Monday and we'll stick with the
animal theme but the domesticated kind
for all you pet owners we want to see
your Furry Friends decked out in their
most festive outfits send your photos to
viewers at global.com and we'll air the
best ones on Christmas Eve good luck to
all you cats and dogs kangaroos need not
apply thanks for watching Donna will be
back here with you tomorrow have a great
night
[Music]